[Music]
we all played with toys when we were
younger but let's face it some toys are
creepy stay tuned to find out why you
should never buy a collector's doll are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more great content
like this now on to 10 disturbing toys
that were caught moving on camera ghosts
or possessed toy how many of you played
with toys when you were younger we bet
most of you have you ever played with
the toy and then had to leave the room
in a hurry only to find that when you
came back the toy was in a different
position you probably thought that you
were going crazy but this video proves
that you might not have been as far off
as you thought the video posted by
Aussie films starts out pretty normal it
shows a toy soldier resting on a car
probably left there by the kid who owns
both toys but soon the toy soldier
starts moving on his own but then he
stops just as quickly as he started
making us wonder if we even saw what we
thought we did then the toy starts to
move again until it moves completely off
the truck and onto the ground and then
out of the frame insane right but that's
not everything even the truck starts
moving the video suggests that it was a
ghost that was moving everything around
but we have a different idea
maybe the toys are possessed some people
believe that the guy filming was using a
remote control to move the car which
could be true but how can anyone explain
the soldier moving Elf on a shelf
everyone knows Elf on a shelf he's a
little Christmas elf dressed in Santa
clothing that people typically put out
around Christmas time if you ask us
we've always thought those little elves
on shelves were a little creepy but now
we've got proof to back us up it all
went down in the northern Life newsroom
in 2013 in the video posted by Sudbury
comm you can see the elf sitting on
someone's desk the office is completely
empty as everyone must have left for the
night then the elfs eyes start moving
now this isn't really that alarming
because moving eyes can be added in with
special effects in animation what is
really weird is what happens after the
elf starts to move around the desk he
then goes to turn on the christmas light
on the Christmas tree on the desk after
that he looks into the camera we
couldn't help but feel a little chill as
he stared back at us through the camera
then he starts to run all around the
office if you ever doubted that toys
moved on their own then this should stop
all of those doubts this else is clearly
alive or possessed Woody's alive
if you've ever seen any of the Toy Story
movies then you know that toys are more
than they seem in the film they have
whole lives outside of what we see when
we play with them well this video posted
by Leo Kim video may show that Toy Story
was a true story in the video a dad and
his son are at the toy store looking at
a woody doll the dad says that he and
his son have just seen woody Moo
he then zooms in on the doll and you can
see that the doll is no longer in the
correct place in the box he's actually
slouched down on the bottom side of the
box as if he tried to escape and then he
had to stop because people came up and
started watching him we wonder what
would have happened if this dad and son
hadn't walked up would the Woody doll
have actually made a run for it and
escaped then there would have just been
an empty box on the shelf
what would the toy store think happened
they would probably just assume that
they were sent an empty box and no one
would ever realize that the toys were
alive and woody actually escaped scary
baby this next video is proof that you
should never mistreat your toys why
because they may be alive the video
posted by [ __ ] Urkel's starts out with
a girl saying how means she and her
friend had been to a doll that they
found in her spare bedroom they threw it
down the stairs held it underwater and
other horrible things and then the doll
randomly started laughing so they threw
it down the stairs out of fear
once they picked it up again they
started thinking that maybe the doll was
just laughing because it was on so then
they turned the doll around to see if it
was on and once they opened her battery
pack they saw that the doll was never on
the doll eventually stopped making
noises but it never stopped moving
it kept moving its eyes and mouth the
whole time the video was pretty scary to
watch just as someone viewing from home
we can't imagine what it must have been
like for those kids we wouldn't be able
to sleep through the night with that
doll in the house
they should throw it out as quickly as
possible moving eyes if you're thinking
about getting an elf on the shelf just
don't do it there's absolutely no reason
to put such a thing in your home if you
are in need of a little extra holiday
cheer and simply go find some Christmas
lights but do not get an Elf on a shelf
we repeat do not get one this is the
second video we've seen about elves on
shelves coming to life the video posted
by Arnaldo lopez may actually be scarier
than the last Elf on a shelf video so
the Lopez family ordered an elf on the
shelf and then it came to their house on
December 1st which is plenty of time to
display before Christmas but seven days
before Christmas everything changed in
the video you just see the elf who's
apparently named Carol sitting on a
table at first it seems like nothing is
wrong but all of a sudden Carol moves
her eyes the person holding the camera
then screams and starts running away can
you imagine if you were just looking at
a doll and all of a sudden it moved its
eyes and what is even weirder if that
hadn't moved its eyes the whole time it
was there it waited until it been there
for awhile before it decided to show its
true colors creepy doll collection we
all played with Barbie dolls when we
were younger that is pretty normal but
what is it with people who insist on
having doll collections and it's usually
not normal dolls either
it's creepy collectors dolls they're
usually made out of porcelain and look
like something straight out of a scary
movie anyway
in this clip posted by unexplained
mysteries you can see someone
videotaping their doll collection just
the video of them showing off their
dolls is creepy enough the dolls look
like they are just waiting to commit
some type of crime but the video gets
even creepier halfway through the clip
you can see one of the dolls move we
could barely even watch the whole clip
without freaking out if you haven't
watched the video yet we suggest that
you don't watch it if you're at home
alone but if you must watch the video
alone just be aware that it's very
creepy if this had happened to us we
would have just thrown all the dolls
away no reason to keep them if they're
gonna come alive in the middle of the
night and hurt us
don't buy dolls you haven't gotten the
memo yet then you definitely under no
circumstance should buy dolls it's just
not worth it they will inevitably come
to life and hurt you in this next clip
that was also posted by unexplained
mysteries there's another creepy doll
the owner had said they had heard the
doll moving on its own at night so they
decided to set it up in front of a
camera when the owner walked away the
doll slowly started moving first it
started moving its arm out and then back
in once it was done doing that it
decided to turn and look at the camera
if this isn't the scariest thing that
we've ever seen then we don't know what
is first of all if you think that your
doll is moving then why even set up a
video to see instead it would make more
sense to just get rid of the doll
there's no point in waiting for it to
hurt you if the doll is alive it has to
go there's no way around it also we
don't understand why so many people are
into scary looking dolls why would you
want to buy something that already looks
like it's up to no good
Toy Story is real obviously we can't
talk about dolls coming to life without
talking about Toy Story
we've already rotted up once but this
time it's the whole Toy Story gang
that's coming to life and freaking us
out so in this clip posted by viral top
5th the whole Toy Story gang is laying
on the ground who knows why anyone would
want to buy all the Toy Story characters
considering their affinity for coming
alive but that's none of our business
anyway the owner of the toys leaves the
room and almost as soon as they do
woody starts moving he moves his arm
first and then he stands up before
falling back down
we told you that you shouldn't buy Toy
Story dolls the movie is literally about
them coming to life so why would you
expect anything from them besides them
coming to life what's weird though is
that the other dolls didn't move
maybe woody usually gets up to check and
make sure the coast is clear maybe
that's why he just got up and then laid
back down maybe he heard someone coming
back or something so he's signal to
everyone to stay still that would
actually make a lot of sense van get
away while we're on the topic of Toy
Story toys we have got to show you this
video if you think toys just sitting up
was bad then have we got something for
you not only can' toys wake up and move
of their own volition they can also go
outside yes you that is right they can
go outside in this clip by viral top v
we see woody hanging from the back of a
van how did he get there you probably
woke up and attached himself to the van
but what's even weirder is that he's
swinging his legs as if he's trying to
get on the van is that not the creepiest
thing that you have ever seen which
leads us to a bigger question are the
toys that are waking up friendly or are
they all bent on destroying us if the
second option is true then the family
that's in that van should be very very
afraid
why would woody go through so much
trouble to get on that van
it's truly frightening he seems so human
after watching all of these videos of
Toy Story characters coming to life can
we all agree to leave those toys in the
store beanie boo we all have our
favorite stuffed animals they keep us
safe and help us sleep at night well
that's what they usually do but in this
particular video posted by tabbies
universe this beanie boo did the
complete opposite the video starts with
the person recording saying that she
doesn't know what to do she says that
the night before she and a man named Tom
were woken up by a loud noise it sounded
like something had fallen in the other
room she told Tom to get up and go see
what it was he did and when he came back
he was absolutely frightened he said
that their beanie boo was in the middle
of the other room since that wasn't
where they had left it
they were both shocked at this discovery
so they decided to go back to sleep but
to leave Tom's camera on and recording
the beanie boo didn't move positions for
the rest of the night but what it did do
was much worse it waved at the camera
isn't that just insane it's like he knew
that they were recording and wanted to
make sure that everyone knew that he
knew it's like he didn't care at all he
wants everyone to know that he's alive
and can do whatever he wants and that's
the scariest part of all that's it for
10 disturbing toys that were caught
moving on camera did any of these toys
scare you let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
[Music]